they got paid they could cash them back
in I guess to to the company that sold
the tickets
I don't know if they got you into the
park though
I don't remember I think like because I
was pretty little
but I remember paying
like the there was admission to get into
Disney but it wasn't that much yeah but
then you had to buy books so it was more
like a standard like County Fair where
you had to buy like tickets to go into
the rides and obviously the good [__]
like Space Mountain was like they didn't
give you as many of those so you had to
buy extra ones that were more expensive
but you know the little stuff like the
dumbos and stuff like that I think that
was just like an a ticket or something
because there's like kitty right
oh man I gotta update this after the
show I guess it's giving me the little
yellow sign
ah
Star Market yeah
Social Security shopping and I said man
that's where all the women are they said
we're just Star Market they would
actually dress up women would dress up
and go to Star Market and even it was
obvious that they were Cruiser for dudes
in there
it was like a basket you know what I
mean they have bad they they bought very
little but they're obviously just
walking around and around they might
have been you know it's kind of the
Boston area so maybe they're just
killing time I forgot to put the um the
um what you call it on the starting soon
yeah so we're already on oh yeah
I guess as soon as I started Trey said
do you all not realize you're live no I
didn't no
um because what happened we've been
alive
um well let me see
two minutes and 20 seconds never hear me
talking myself in the [__] Star
Market yeah yeah yeah that's all but
yeah and I didn't do the intro but
whatever whatever [__] it well because
what usually happens is I set up the
broadcast
and then
um you know and then I leave that up for
five minutes and then I put on the
starting soon thing and then I let that
go for five minutes but I forgot to put
that on because you were talking and I
got distracted I guess yeah but yeah so
we were like two minutes we didn't do
anything like we didn't do anything bad
though which is good
[Laughter]
and then they kick us off YouTube yeah
I was just saying earlier man for can I
put my glasses on I was reading some
stuff and I [__] saw myself on the
screen and I said God damn these glasses
make me look older and she goes no they
don't you look the same and I'm looking
at it goes oh what it is I could see
myself
and I was like laughing at her because
so much better when I was blurry
yeah because look like if I take my
glasses off it's like oh look I look I
look how beautiful yeah just because I'm
because I just look like a white smudge
without any wrinkles or anything like
that yeah Trey said the notification
went up but I clicked it I was like what
yeah that was uh that was my bad I just
I you know I'm tired and I wasn't I
wasn't really thinking about it but like
I said it's the Sidetrack show it's a
[__] it it's not like super important
that we do the intro or anything like
that yeah like I said it's a good thing
we weren't doing anything embarrassing
we usually aren't though
that's not what we're sitting here yeah
we're just we're just sitting here
waiting for the time to just sit here
and get ready make sure drinks are good
um yapping about stuff yeah we're
getting ready to uh we're gonna go we're
gonna go out tonight yeah even though
I'm super sleepy but I'll I'll wake up
when I get there I guess yeah
I'm gonna go to mannequin so they got a
damn dress code and a cover charge now
try to keep all the Riff raffs out try
to keep the goth Purity level high I'm
actually glad they did I was surprised
because that was my suggestion man well
yeah well for I guess more than one
person suggested it then because like
Tina wrote this big and she's uh you
know kind of the door person and the um
you know her husband Paul is the DJ and
has been for a really long time and she
wrote this big long post about uh you
know trying to keep out you know it's
like we wanted this place to be like you
know weirdos like safe for weird people
yeah yeah you know and everybody and
she's like so well and the thing about
it and I actually didn't know this but
apparently the city of Sanford has been
like harassing uh big Tom and like you
know the club just because like all the
weirdos hanging out like in front of the
yeah you can't stay outside yeah because
it's stuff and everything like that so I
guess Big Time decided well [__] that
I'm just gonna double down so he's like
now we want furries and drag queens and
everything's like just everybody as
freaky as possible like get down there
like out in front of the [__] club I
was like see I like that I like that but
I like that they um yeah I was surprised
they went that far because for a long
time
the Friday is called venue 13 which is
what that night has been called even way
before it was even at mannequins it was
it's been at like lots of other venues
for years and years and it was always
called that and Tina messaged me the
other day and she said we're doing a new
thing on Fridays like I wasn't allowed
to announce it then because it was still
a secret but you know obviously it's
tonight so everybody knows about it now
but they're like we changed it to freak
Show Fridays so we're gonna do so I did
like a poster with all like old school
Sideshow performers and stuff like that
on it
and uh they and they started doing I she
didn't tell me they started doing a
dress code but that makes me really
happy because there's really not any
clubs around here that do that and I've
always been [__] and I think that's a
good I always wished like when I was
going to the castle I always wish the
castle would Implement that but they
never they have dress codes for like
special events like the vampire ball and
stuff like that you can't just walk in
off the street but well the Castle's so
famous yeah the only people showing up
pretty much are people with uh
people who are Goths and in there in
outfits and if you show up in there just
a regular clothes you're in a definite
minority people are looking at you like
what the [__] are you doing in here they
got a dude named Senator walking around
nothing but just to have a g straight
you damn 60 something almost 70 year old
man walking around naked
yeah in there he's famous yeah that dude
everybody knows who that guy is just
yeah Trey said I saw a skinny puppy in
Atlanta last night [__] amazing show
oh I'm jealous
yeah I think some people well when was I
think they played down here but I don't
know when or they are gonna play down
here can you probably yeah they paid a
couple years back remember yeah I know
that um there's another there's a show
in
Tampa tonight it might be Covenant I
think covenant's playing in Tampa
tonight so some people might be going to
that they're pretty good yeah I don't
think I've ever seen them live now that
I think about it I've seen like VNV
Nation and yeah I saw them a long time
ago let me get some ice here but um
Trey said they were just near you one
show got canceled yeah that's right I
remember seeing it on Facebook because a
lot of people were pissed off about that
and they're in Charlotte tonight I don't
think I've ever have I ever seen skinny
puppy
I've seen so many shows and I can't even
I'm pretty sure I have but it's been a
really long time and I can't remember
John Smith said I went to see the Damned
last week back with the original lineup
tour that's cool like were they were
they really awesome did they like look
the same or did they look like a bunch
of old [__] let me get that ice
yeah it's ice as well oh you didn't put
turn the fan on oh okay yeah I was
wondering why it was that hot in here
yeah
what's that all about
I still can't believe I turned the [__]
on without
putting the starting suit thank God like
it's been a long day you know what I
mean I don't know I didn't really get
much sleep last night like I woke up at
two something because I had to pee and
then I got back in bed and I couldn't
really go back to sleep so I'm laying
there until like quarter to four and
then I have to get up at five so I
didn't really
oh thanks and then today was kind of
like really really busy at work and I
was just kind of
the other guys Trey saying yeah that he
thought I was looking on my tablet
looking at it I was but you see when
we're running this [__]
on the screen in front of us
even before it's streaming we see
ourselves and it's moving live yeah I
looked here and I saw ourselves moving
live
but I didn't realize there was a delay I
didn't realize that it was that that was
this show that we were streaming I
didn't realize it yeah because I saw
well clearly
hi Pokey we were just talking about you
yeah
okay
right I thought you were realizing what
was going on no I was looking at it even
register it's just normal because it
looked just well yeah because like I
said I use OBS and I have it open on my
laptop and we can see ourselves like
before
you know before we start streaming like
we can see ourselves on the camera so
it's like so that's probably why I did
it like register because I was just kind
of like whatever my [__] is offline here
John Smith says Dave vanion has barely
aged everyone else not so much
yeah Trey said my birthday's in a week
so that was my birthday celebration last
night seeing skinny puppy well happy
early birthday they were good live every
time I've seen them
we didn't see them together did we or
did we yeah saw them together that's
right that's right that's right that's
Sonya was with us yeah that's right I
knew I'd [__] seen them
we got pictures of me you and Sonia at
the show that's right
that's right yep you're a good laugh
weren't they at um
what the [__] is the name of that place
the place that was next to ibar the old
Eye bar I can't remember the hell
Firestone no it's not Firestone
firestone's down the street um next to
ibar yeah it's like remember there's
like yeah yeah yeah how much we saw I
just I always forget the name of that
[__] place I don't remember what then
it had a different name at that time I
think is it the B it's the beach yeah I
guess so I think it was the beach I used
to see him in Detroit where they were a
local band they were just from across
the
across the uh the bridge in Ontario
and they used to they were like the
local band they didn't even like be
backstage they were just like hanging
out up front
at the bar
before the show and after the show and
we didn't realize how great they were
they were just like a local band to us
yeah
um they used to see what Kevin key and
[__] what's his name ogre yeah his
real name is David Ogilvy I think in it
or ogre I think just ogre
they were older than I was they were far
too cool for me to [__] hang out with
at that time that was even before I went
into the army
they had [__] hot women with them too
it was like [__] death rock chicks
and [__] ripped up
ripped up fish nets and pixie boots and
PVC Ultra mini skirts they look like
[__] Undead hookers
looking back on it they were they were
kind of dressed like some of you see
from folks Alien Sex Fiend or [__]
yeah specimen something like that
but I was just like you know I was kind
of new to the scene then I was just like
oh man look at this
vampire hookers man it doesn't get any
better than this you know it really
doesn't no
it doesn't
and Detroit was the [__] back then it
was like something out of the crow late
80s
Jasmine says skinny puppy story oh you
are okay I got for free that one night
that that they were there this was that
I don't remember if that was at St
Andrews Hall
or a city club or the shelter it was one
of those three
the show was that night but I don't
think it was at the same place that they
played that they were hanging out and I
got a uh one of the guys that were with
them and their little crew was giving
out free cassette tapes
and they had they were
[__] professionally printed and
everything it was looked like they came
out of a major label you know they're
white with all the [__] songs printed
on them
and I've never seen it again it was like
an EP it was called Church in hell that
was the name of the [__] thing it was
and it was pretty cool man and the song
on it the only good song I Really
remember was just called Church in hell
maybe a skinny pepper fans and [__]
freaks might know exactly what that was
I think it had maybe about six songs on
it maybe eight
yeah I lost it though my no I don't
remember what happened to it I had at
the time I had a
rusted out [__] Detroit bomber it was
a [__] 73 Lincoln Mercury Montego
I had a whole thing on [__] spray
painted on it I had Shogun Warriors
[__]
strapped to the [__] front of the
grill look like some out of Mad Max it
did in the hood I wouldn't spray painted
a giant rat skull on it with crossbones
it looked like I even glued on on the
back bumper I glued a bunch of army man
it was [__] it was my goth ride well
I had to sucking craco I think it was
craco it was like something you got from
uh from from the from from auto parts
store it's like a craco [__] tape
player
the best tape player I could afford at
that time than the [__] uh uh
big speakers and [__]
and I was [__] jamming all different
kinds of tapes and one day I was jamming
the [__] church at Hell tape and the
[__] kraco ate it oh hate to take and
I got it for free when that happened
yeah and and that was not a [__]
skinny puppy album you could buy they
were giving it away for free
that sucks I had that happen to so many
of my kids remember back in the old days
when like you [__] you play tapes too
many times and then you shoot would eat
it yeah and then like you desperately
like pull it all out and try to like
wheel it all back in there with a pencil
and chill yeah the kids today they don't
know the struggling
they had to make your own golf clothes
and [__]
look like a [__] low budget Andrew
Eldritch I had that same [__] hair
[__] I had the damn engineer boots
with the rings on the side overcoats it
was Detroit it was [__] freezing
yeah just black jeans and [__]
red dark red satin shirts and [__] it
was even a fake satin that used to be
real popular it's kind of yeah yeah we
had that I had that had all different
kinds of [__]
band T-shirts and stuff
yeah just there's another time you know
it was kind of like in in those days it
was goth and [__] industrial and punk
was punk rock was all just kind of the
same thing it was kind of fused together
it was started to spread apart I guess
it was it's just
they were all happening in the same in
New York looked very different than
Detroit
the Detroit scene looked like something
out of the first Crow movie
but it looked like
Trey says I [__] love Detroit man
yeah and that was in a time when most of
it was still standing I think that's all
torn down a lot of it now
they had [__]
60-story skyscrapers that had been
abandoned for [__] decades just
sitting there like these [__] spooky
ass models it looked like I [__] City
they've been destroyed like in a war
yeah
and they would just people would just
set fire to houses for on Devil's Night
for fun they're abandoned houses but
they're just the city was just consuming
itself
I never had a problem with it though
nobody ever [__] with me
it's weird you know what I mean it had
bad cry but
that was just a young white guy and they
just they ignored me I guess I [__]
went out one night one day to go to work
I was working a place called Spring
engineering and I was come out through
the back gate was walking walking
towards my car and behind the apartment
was a dumpster at that time and sticking
out of the dumpster with [__] feet
with his shoes gone
I [__] looked in there and it was
just a frozen [__] dead dude in there
black guy yeah yeah
shot up and dead he threw him in the
[__] dumpster took his shoes
I don't know who he was or anything they
came and got him out of there
well I hope so yeah
well evidently they [__] would uh
tear down buildings and find bodies and
wear the duty been in there for [__]
20 years dead
yeah do you know who that is yeah well
it might just be a vagrant that died in
here you know yeah it's like if nobody
goes in there yeah he wouldn't yep
foreign
yeah Trey said they played at St Andrews
pretty much every time they played
Detroit Andrews my lady friend who lives
yeah right because I used to go to San
Andreas all the time
the ones that I would hit was Saint
Andrews the shelter and then City Club
and I think I remember remember
correctly I think City Club opened up a
little bit later I think that might have
been 89 or at least that's when I
started going
my 80s 88 Maybe 89.
yeah you're a couple years older than me
I wasn't old enough to go clubbing it
and because I didn't turn 18 until 1990.
they were cheap Man clubs were cheap
back then you could get a beer for a
dollar
oh what kind of beer just don't tap in a
plastic like it's probably Bud Light or
Schaefer's known Detroit it's probably
Shaffers
I don't I never
yes that was the Rock Bottom for I never
I've never I'm not a big beer person and
then another one it was it was like one
it was just like a little step above it
was I think it was called Rolling Rock
well I've heard of that yeah Rolling
Rock was a little bit above that I don't
think I've ever had it yeah like I've
seen it in the storm so I think they
still sell that don't they I think so
the green bottle
yeah yeah
I don't remember ever drinking it though
like I said I'm not a real big beer
person like there's some beers that I
like but I'm not a connoisseur and I
don't really
you know I don't really know this so
like I like Killian's red I like um
uh I like Guinness I like uh
uh I like a lot of those coffee Stouts
and stuff like that somebody I don't
remember who it was they used to make a
vanilla Stout that was really good yeah
and I like like pumpkin ales and things
Camp God knows about it it's a Shapers
is [__] cheap cheap cheap beer yeah
piss water
you get drunkard though well you know
anything that has alcohol in it yeah you
probably you get drunk on NyQuil if you
drink enough
and you just like
you could get like a whole picture of of
[__] like Shaffer I remember you could
get a picture too and it was probably
like only five or six bucks
so
what a deal yeah such a bargain yeah
I mean if you're if you're not gonna be
snotty about it you're like well I'm
just gonna drink enough to like get [__]
faced Detroit wasn't snotty at all
that's what I mean half half the goth
kids in the scene were squatting they
were squatting in abandoned houses and
abandoned buildings yeah because why why
pay rent you could get basically the
same thing
for free and the and the owners were
long gone and they eventually tore and
all that stuff down the only difference
was and some of it still had power water
and electricity you know electricity and
water right they couldn't evidently they
didn't have the wherewithal to shut
power supply down you know maybe it was
in a neighborhood where some of the
houses still had resumes right so that's
what I'm thinking they couldn't shut the
water off
well I mean that's the thing if I found
a [__] apartment that had all the
power and everything like that and there
were houses most of the time they were
houses yeah I'd move my ass in there yep
and the whole all that live for free
yeah that sounds nice you guys can look
at it on on YouTube you know
the whole street might look ransacked
but then like you'd be take over one of
those houses and kind of just like fix
it up a little bit and have a car out in
front nobody ever bother you
I should have done it but I had I had
enough money to actually have like I
lived in a cat a converted cattle
slaughterhouse for a while and lived
there and I always lived at the
Wellesley
building called the wells they heard
it's all college kids living at the
Wellesley now but when I lived at the
Wellesley it was [__] kind of rough
you know what I mean it was right near
Cass corridor
to Detroit people know what I'm talking
about yeah I lived off Cass
that was like the heart of it
I was gonna say the uh the horror movie
that came out last year like or earlier
this year called Barbarian that was one
of the um
kind of one one of the uh
uh premises of the movie was that she
stays at this Airbnb and she gets there
into the dark and like the house looks
nice and everything but then the next
day it's in the middle of this popped
out Detroit like neighborhood and all
the other houses are abandoned like she
didn't realize because it was like dark
when she came in there
uh slasher friend said I bet the next
movie you review will be that Renfield
movie with Nicholas Cage yeah I saw that
that came out because I saw like a
couple of other like channels reviewing
it and I really want to see it it looks
hilarious but um we actually have to
review Louie sent us
training day and also sent us Breakfast
Club like a long time ago so we have to
do either both of those or one of those
or something Day first we'll get we'll
get to that but I definitely do want to
see that Renfield movie that looks
delightful I just saw another trailer
for it too like a different one and that
looks it looks really really funny
uh Victor said barbarian was a fun movie
I really liked Barbarian I know that it
was um I didn't get to see it you would
probably like it I feel like yeah
um I feel like it was kind of like
divisive but I I really liked it a lot I
thought it was pretty cool because you
liked that one we saw in the theater
malignant right
which one was that that was the one with
the with the woman with the face on the
back of her face you know what I mean
face on the back of her face she had
like the back of her head well you know
she was like uh I don't quite remember
that one yeah I really really liking
that it kind of reminded me a little bit
of that even though it's like not
exactly the same we saw it in the
theater yeah
uh refresh my memory tell me how that
one went I don't remember that well it
was kind of like well now I can't
remember now that you've like put me on
the spot but it's just kind of like it
was this woman that um what the [__] and
she would remember she would kind of
like phase out and then she would see
she thought she was psychic because she
would see like all these murders and
[__] like that going on but then it
turned out that spoiler alert it was
really her doing it but it was like
it should be like backwards she'd be
like walking around backwards and [__]
oh yeah yeah it was like an action movie
almost yeah kind of like toward the end
yeah it's pretty good yeah so the well
Barbarian is kind of like that in the
sense that it starts out as one kind of
movie and you're kind of like not sure
how everything goes together and then it
kind of goes in a different direction
but in a but in a good way I actually
really liked it
um
Camp guy said I make wine with Welch's
grape juice sugar and yeast yeah have a
high hydrometer or hydrometer to get the
sugar right at the very beginning of the
fermentation also have two one gallon
jugs with airlocks I've never tried to
make wine I tried to make ginger beer
like a long time ago and it was all
right mine's pretty easy
well the Wine's a lot easier to make the
beer
beer has to be kind of fermented and
there's like a mash you have to make and
there's a lot of heating involved the
time a bunch of different equipment a
bunch of different components had to be
just right it's like baking almost
yeah it's pretty serious my friend Steve
that I grew up with he owned his own
micro Brewery for a while right there in
Detroit trying to remember what it was
called
something another Brewery
I have to remember
's Hammer might remember Steve's company
he they sold quite a bit of beer a lot a
lot of places bought it but it was kind
of a higher end microbrewery type beer
I think was called [__] Michigan
Michigan something another Brewery oh no
yeah I don't remember I don't remember
Motor City Brewery or something like
that
I don't remember
if I heard it again I'd remember it was
something like that
I had he had a bunch of different
flavors
you know and they were all good
a lot of dark beers
that he could make it
yeah my like like I said I try to make
ginger beer which is not alcoholic but
you make it kind of the same way I'd
like to learn how to make vodka
yeah can you make vodka at home I guess
yeah make it a still
yeah maybe we should make our own vodka
you might end up saving us a lot of
money
Camp guy said it's just a hobby to make
wine there's no way I could make enough
to satisfy my needs yeah
how much wine do you need you can use a
lot a lot evidently yeah I wonder if
we'd be able to like make enough vodka
to meet our needs probably not because
we do drink a lot of vodka
uh Mark says I'll drink Killians and
Rolling Rock uh Rolling Rock tastes good
yeah I've heard Rolling Rock was okay
but I don't think I've ever had it
before
I I know almost nothing about beer to be
honest
they only don't like beers that much
yeah I'm like real dark like Stouts and
I like some uh vitans which are like
[__] sweet kind of German white beers
are pretty good
um some red beer sir I just in general I
don't really like beer that much it's
too fattening and too filling for me it
makes me sleepy yeah
every time we constantly pissing every
time we go because sometimes we go
places that don't you know it doesn't
have a liquor license so then I'll get
beer like because for a long time Will's
Pub didn't have one so I'd always get
beer when I went there but you know I'd
have one or two and then I'd be like
dozing off you know
my favorite beer drink is Black Velvet
if you please yeah Black Velvet which is
cider some kind of hard cider it can be
pear apple
mixed with equal part
Stout like get a stout of work just any
kind of black beer it's [__] that's
good yeah like 50 50.
Victor said you can take any cheap vodka
and run it through a Brita filter
pitcher and it'll taste like high-end
[__]
that's funny I never even thought of
doing that we have a Brita
yeah the difference is though it's only
a couple dollars you can get Sky for
just only a couple dollars more than
yeah and I mean and I know that's not
like super high end but it's not it's
not you know it's not [__] it's not
Aristocrat or whatever like the low end
one is yeah wrist terrible
that yeah and it's like look I've even
had like you know Stoli and stuff like
that which is you know I don't like
slowly that much right but it's better
than Aristocrat yeah that was always at
ibar that was always like the well which
one drink like no Aristocrat yeah and it
was just like I don't I'm sure they sell
it in liquor stores but it's like I
never but that [__] tastes like I don't
know holy crap
next drink you know like if you're
getting a Tokyo tea or a [__] red
death or something where it's just all
[__]
well it's all alcohol you know like like
a like a Long Island iced tea it doesn't
really matter because so much shit's in
there everything everything cancels
everything else out
well that's kind of the magic of those
kind of drinks like Tokyo tea and Long
Island iced tea and red death and stuff
like that it's like they're pretty much
all alcohol but they don't taste like
alcohol which is it's like fruit punches
which is kind of like a magic trick
because for a while like sometimes I get
Red Death which tastes kind of like a
Hawaiian Punch like pretty much but
man you have two or three of those and
you're on the [__] floor yeah they're
very strong
they absolutely don't taste like it
though yeah if you've ever had Tokyo tea
Tokyo tea is green it's bright green
looks like [__]
looks like a [__] radiator fluid is
that the one with melon rice in it is it
melon what's more
and it tastes
just like um
a [__] green tea
yeah like a sweet green tea
and you can pound it you can slam it if
you wanted to but uh I wouldn't advise
it
yeah I wanted to buy this it's just
another variant of Long Island iced tea
that always kind of blew my mind that
there's that whole subcategory of drinks
I don't even know if it has like a name
or anything like that but that are
pretty much all the alcohols like mixed
together with maybe like a little
flavoring like liqueur and a tiny bit of
soda or something and it's like they'll
taste like like you said like iced tea
or you know fruit punch or something
like that but they're super super strong
yeah you never know and they don't taste
like it and I'm just like how the [__]
did they even pull that off yeah there's
times when I was just staggering out of
there yeah after [__] I don't think
I've ever managed more than three of
them like an even and after three of
them I was like my vision was blurry
yeah you know what I mean that was one
of those nights where you were throwing
up in a car
yeah probably although usually if I
don't know if I'm gonna throw up in the
car that's it's usually gin and tonic so
yeah because and that's usually because
it's not that acid but yeah I think
remember you were just delirious and I
think I think that was a red death I
think that was a red death knight yeah
yeah I think five of them [__] things
I don't think that was that was when
ibar was rolling I don't think I've ever
managed five of them
there was a time when ibar was [__]
super rolling and uh people would come
in and buy us free drinks so people were
making lots of money the economy was
going real good
I'm gonna have somebody like [__]
Scott
he's my hooker buddy and [__] he'll
come in and he'll just start [__]
buying buying me and Jan [__] round
after round of drinks and shots and
shots and stuff yeah I call him a hooker
buddy because he's always showing up
with hookers a different one yeah
different one every time and I says and
I start threatening him about it says
what's her contract is she does she do
does she do couples that kind of [__] he
starts he has protective instincts over
his hookers
and he's like what what are you talking
about what is that it says dude dude
she's a pro she said but we can't share
hookers what do you buy it doesn't start
breaking him down slowly he goes yeah
yeah yeah I guess we can't it's you
you're attacked you got emotional
feelings you coffee you caught feelings
for that hooker didn't you and he's oh
no no no
he's he's building a [__] club
well it's done I think it opens next
month yeah in downtown Stanford yeah we
work with him we work we do some graphic
design for him and
uh
he went on test man
he's this he's younger than me he looks
a lot older than me all right
all right Short Round
Short Round yeah short yeah a few shorts
like a white hair and just look like an
old man
I got his ass on test and didn't see him
for a long time
how long how long have we had not seen
him maybe six months four months I don't
think it had been that long before five
months yeah and he shows up at the club
with with one of his little [__] 20
year old hookers
and I'm going I said I said Jen is is
that Scott and she was I don't know I
was like I think that's good I think it
is but is that Scott but it also kind of
does like it looks like him but it does
yeah so I'm walking up to him and wasn't
really sure it was him sounds like yeah
it is
he had grown about three inches taller
and that's why I didn't recognize yeah
he grown about three inches tall he
looked a lot better
and says dude man you [__] changed
yours yeah I'm taller all my [__]
spine stretched out and all the first
all my fluids dressed up and it says
yeah you've lost a little bit of weight
too and he goes yeah
so and then I told him I said um
what you need to do man is you need to
[__] hire me as your [__] personal
trainer
and [__] in in 18 months you you know
we'll get you on some better juice get
you on some good sauce 18 bucks you'll
look a lot closer to me that like me you
that changed your life and he goes oh
let me let me process this let me
process this okay yeah yeah yeah so I
contact him later you know so you you
want to come train with me because got
my own Trader that says he [__] you
and he goes yeah yeah but he's near me
you know he goes I'm going I'm going to
train and [__] yeah he don't want to
drive away the [__] yeah yeah he does
too far
three days a week I'm in a gym so we're
gonna see we're gonna see what happens
to him
get his ass on [__] MPP or something
John Smith said if you ever ask for a
Mojito bartenders hate you because
they're an ass to make an ass
you gotta you can only get those at
restaurants and stuff around here really
yeah I don't I've never heard of anybody
ordering one I mean I guess technically
you could I mean they have all the stuff
but yeah they probably like roll their
eyes like oh Jesus Oh you gotta have
fresh mint for it no they're not gonna
carry that that's true yeah and the real
one's not it's not even mint that they
use it's uh it's like a weed that comes
from Puerto Rico I think it's like not
weed yeah it's like just some plant that
they have it the closest thing too would
be mint but I don't think it's actually
meant
it's mint adjacent yeah Dave is here hey
yo where the white woman at white women
out here well there's ones right here
hello YouTube hi Dave what's up you
going to mannequins tonight because we
are I wanna I wanna investigate this new
thing that they're doing because I'm
very happy about it see if I think she
even put in the post she's gonna be
working the door keeping all the Cairns
and normies out yeah and the Frat Boys
so I'm like okay let's see how this
affects the [__] uh till
yeah we'll see that's what I was kind of
worried about it but well a lot of like
our a lot of our crowd I feel like had
not like had stopped going because of
that of the reason of all the douchebags
like being in there and it's like yeah
we just we wanted to go hang out I think
he's gonna have a first couple I think
the first couple weeks is going to be
weak
yeah I mean it's gonna take a while for
the [__] feedback to get in the
system
everybody was talking about that post
that Tina made though all right well I
mean like I said I'm not on Facebook all
the time but I saw it this morning and a
lot of people commented on they were
like oh my God awesome you know I mean I
think Angel reposted it and like a bunch
of different people there's like hey no
more Frat Boys yay
hahaha
uh it says hero my favorite goth couple
hi there what's going on where's your
Yoda Kitty oh she's running around who's
asking this I can't see
Mackie Mac VR chat I don't know that one
yeah yeah that's a new person it's not
new they they're they've been here
before I recognize that um and Dave said
yeah he'll be there I don't know where
where Pookie is she was here a second
ago she gets bored if we're not like
talking to her so she's just like [__]
you guys I'm gonna go find something
else to do I'm gonna go sit by my water
fountain she was pestering you last
night I know I got up in bed and all of
a sudden [__] Pookie jumps over me
and starts [__] jumping up and down
on her yeah
yeah I was like okay I'm trying to sleep
yeah and it's like three o'clock in the
morning yeah
I think maybe that's why I was dreaming
about her I think that's why like she
woke me up because I was having a dream
and then I woke up and yeah say
grandpars what was what was Steve's Brew
micro Brewery called Do You Remember
I don't think you were here at the time
I was talking about that time Steve was
running that Brewery it was pretty good
it was something rather City Beer
Steel City Beer I don't remember what it
was called it was pretty good
crafter says so if old Normie grampster
went to mannequins tonight he'd be Sol
and getting inside yeah yeah probably
well okay what she said in the post she
wrote like a big long post
she's like basically Motor City Brewing
that's right he remembered what it was
well you got it mostly yeah you said
Motor City breweries yeah that's what I
thought yeah yeah but she said that um
honestly you either have to look if you
don't have it doesn't have to be goth
she's like and it's just any kind of
alternative sub-genre is fine but also
she's like or you have to be
she said either known to us or known
like friend of a friend or have somebody
like vouch for you so like if you come
there with people that they know then
they're not gonna like be [__] like
if you're vouching for people
but other than that was it we'll see how
it goes I'm excited about about this uh
what time do we have to end the stream
um probably 30 well now probably
um nine it well yeah maybe 8 30 or a
quarter to nine I mean 9 30 because you
have to get ready I mean my makeup's
done I just have and I have my outfit
picked out there just barely got parking
so no I want to get there on time man
okay so we'll try to cut it out like 8
30 or 8 45 8 30. okay this one we're
gonna cut this this [__] down okay about
30 minutes
yeah I'm gonna warning everybody ahead
of time warn you all ahead of time but I
did get I got us a super chat you guys
well do it now
money money gotta go into Pockets gonna
end up being the bar too okay
well I got one already yeah David bye
Dave will buy you a drink anyway he's
gonna be he's gonna be there in person
Dave's always there
I even tried to Pepper out Dave's buying
drinks I grabbed Dave's hand and I start
moving it towards Jenny's booty that's
just rub real gently don't abuse it
can't do it I can't disrespect like that
it says you're quite a gentleman you're
quite it is you're quite a gentleman not
like you
three sheets to the [__] win yeah
yeah yeah I get [__] up
I get funnier when I get [__] up
though except when I'm on trend yeah
then it's not so funny yes
you think I didn't have a filter you
didn't I think I was filterless before
it's nothing but just a cherry burning
and they're on tread no and drunk
yeah really really not a good situation
I was talking the sofa about that today
she's like she's like yeah you you your
texts you sound a lot more like you were
normally yeah
it was like I had an intensity to me
yeah I mean
I wasn't evil or yeah you're kind of
evil but yeah you kind of have an evil
spirit behind it certain things
but you just there's this intensity
you feel like everything's kind of like
an emergency like it's got to be done
now
it's good for certain things man I would
love to have that [__] in a combat type
situation if you're gonna go fight
somebody [__] Jack yourself up on
Trend about two weeks before you'll be
ready
but just normal life no you don't want
that man
yeah that's that's bad news first couple
months were okay month three four five
was [__] up
thank you Jeffy art have a have a box
wine on me
you know everybody shits on box wine but
I don't I've never had box wine box wine
is good is it a man being my me and my
first wife used to [__] buy box wine
from um uh Walmart because it was cheap
and it was just a regular thing we would
get we'd get like two of them yeah on
the and you know as we were pushing the
car through yeah let's get a couple of
those we were getting like the merlots
right you know yeah and we'd have that
next to the bed up on a little Shelf
yeah
behind one of the nightstands
and just grab a goblet like this get
some wine
that sounds nice actually yeah
and she had a little radio on the other
side this is back in the analog days you
know yeah she put on that NPR what's it
messages from space or whatever it was
[__] sounds from space music from the
hearts of space
[Laughter]
yeah music from the hearts of space sit
there and drink wine and [__] that
sounds nice yeah it was all romantic as
[__]
I got candles and stuff incense burning
we were in our 20s too you know it's
hard you know it's hard to recapture you
know what I mean all that shit's new you
know what I mean you're like oh man yeah
you know but it's just yeah we have to
recapture that [__] you know
well yeah you have to you have to set
the mood yeah you really gotta want to
do it you can't just like sit there and
like look at your tablet every five
minutes well Tiff Tiff was real [__]
ritualistic about stuff she put on her
[__] little goth [__]
um uh
with nightgowns and [__] you know what I
mean [__] with all her [__] fish
nets and [__] and I have my canopy bed
set up so it was all that like you know
what I mean it was all retro vampire
canopy bed set up
she'd start
[__] lighting little [__] candles
and setting up the [__] incense and
[__] and I was like oh here it comes man
here it comes and I'd be getting a
[__]
wine ready and stuff and you know and
just lay around all [__] night in
there
yeah you should have been there Jan you
loved it
I mean you know
to burn candles and incense and all that
kind of stuff listening to music yeah
have all that stuff going yeah she would
have liked you yeah you think she would
have liked you yeah
back in the day yeah in a Time Warp type
situation yeah everybody likes me
I think
[Laughter]
unless people are telling me some [__] I
don't know about
uh grandpa says what is it called bota
bota box Pinot Noir is 16 it's the same
as four bottles and it's you know what
no are I think that's what it was isn't
bad at all yeah that's yeah I kind of
feel like I think that's what it was
even though people make fun I kind of
feel like it can't be that bad yeah
that's what we were getting that we're
getting from Walmart
and we got it as a joke first and had a
little spigot you press the button and
it would just it would it would flow out
of the bottom yeah you know what I mean
they had it had a valve on it right you
know the wine valve it was like why
valve did you ever like just put your
mouth right underneath it would be a
classy
you didn't have to be refrigerated
yeah so you could just keep it right
there right
and then you could uh what was good is
like
if you had ice water all right you could
reach over there and squirt a little bit
of that wine into the ice water and
slightly flavor it oh yeah that's right
that was good too yeah
yeah because I feel like a lot of people
drink wine at like room temperature yeah
right and I'm not about that I put that
piano I like everything to be like super
cold I would put like I would put like
one quarter of a cup into a big [__]
glass of ice water
and just to just color it
and it was it was good yeah see that
sounds good it was good yeah that's
mostly water yeah but it was good I was
thinking about this earlier because
sometimes like when I'm at work I just
you know I get water they have like a
little water machine that you get like
little cold water but they don't have
any ice yeah and for some reason like I
drink water all day long but I'm still
thirsty
like if like room temperature water does
not make me not thirsty only ice water
makes me not thirsty and I have to drink
a lot of it like I'm always like
drinking ice water because I'm always
[__] thirsty and I always have cotton
mouth
so it's like but everything has to be so
it's really kind of annoying like that I
always have to have just
room temperature water like at work all
day it's like because I just feel like
I'm constantly thirsty and I'm drinking
water all day
Grandfather said a great evening drink
is champagne and ripple wine also known
as shampoo yeah
laughs
Trey says back I had to dash through the
shower I just gotten home from work I
basically did an all-nighter last night
yeah I'm just
I'm worn out but I really do want to go
out you know like I was looking forward
to it all yeah even though I'm like
super super tired like even when I was
like driving home I'm like oh my God
please stay awake please stay awake well
you don't have to drive I'll drive it so
well yeah that's not far we're not going
far so yeah yeah you don't have to go
like on a highway or anything like that
it's like not that far away
yeah because I'm after driving like an
hour each way to work is like I'm
[__] tired of driving I filled the
car up with gas this morning though okay
so it's so it's almost fall all right
like I've I realized that
I've been filling up the car
it pretty much shakes out to I have to
fill it up on Tuesday and I have to fill
it up again on Friday
okay every single week
losing a lot of profit I mean we might
not have to because I mean to be fair we
do go out most weekends like go to the
club like either Barbarella or
mannequins and then like a lot of times
we'll go like last weekend for example
we went to koiwan like Saturday night
yeah and that's kind of far so it would
probably be less if we didn't go
anywhere in the weekend but it's like I
don't really want to stay home all
weekend either yeah go doing Saturday at
koi wall it's been a ritual now yeah and
Saturday was actually it was cheaper
remember it wasn't 25 I think it was
only 20. yeah
went there there I went there during the
weekday it was 15.
well they had left they had less out
there they don't have as much stuff yeah
they had that shrimp out there I
punished them for that
Mr how dare they put shrimp out there I
mean like I'm sure they don't feel
punished they were just like yeah eat
the [__]
that's why we put it out there just eat
it they've been having a lot of shrimp
out there matter of fact we're gonna go
tomorrow talk about the shrimp we're
gonna go do you think yeah
they had some of that Cajun shrimp which
it wasn't Cajun it just put some Cajun
seasoning on the shrimp well yeah
and then they have this [__] butter
shrimp which they take a whole shrimp
and batter it in front and deep fry it
yeah they want you to eat the shell and
everything I guess I don't know
well some people do eat the shell yeah I
don't though I'll pull the feet the legs
off of them
you know the little swim arrests yeah
I can't eat the shell dog getting like
yeah like a stomachache
who knows what that does to you you
can't digest that that's what I'm saying
it's like you know my digestive system
is already all [__] jacked so I don't
need that on top of it
Camp guy said fishnets are fish nets are
okay but I prefer Hosiery especially the
old-timey 1950s Style stockings with the
seam down the back yeah those are real
resources yeah they do they look good
with certain outfits but there's
something about goth attire is that it's
that our Traditions are fishnet
now they could be fishing at stocking so
they could be fishnet body like cat suit
you know it could be all that and she
wore all that did you never really could
tell what she was gonna wear
grandpa said if y'all vouch for me at
mannequins I'll voucher at the temple
bar on Cass Avenue in Detroit when you
come visit the great North I'll get you
in there no problem I could ship to the
DJ booth with me
yeah like I said I don't think they're
everybody there they're being you know
if they know who you are or you or they
know somebody that you're with then
there then it's okay
but we'll see how it goes like I said
I'm kind of excited that they actually
took that plunge I didn't think they
would actually do that because
I was under the impression that he was
making so much money like with all those
jackals like wandering in off the street
that he's like yeah let's just keep
doing that but
maybe not
maybe they don't spend that much money
or maybe they don't hang out because
there's other bars down there too so I
feel like they're just going from bar to
bar
and the fact that they were doing that
was maybe
driving away like some of the regulars
which when he opened the bar that's kind
of what he wanted
I mean we met him at ibar and he was
like I wanted a place like in Sanford
that was like that you know what I mean
like for all our people
all our people yeah
so don't think it's racial
well you know we are kind of a race into
our own in a certain way
but uh although we're not it doesn't
have anything to do with what color you
are though
there's just something kind of a
personality aspect that certain type of
people that are attracted to that
uh it's in this area mostly whites and
Hispanics
we do have some black Goths
um [__] Tom big Tom is [__] the
club owner he's a big old ex-navy black
guy
um
I think he's honest with his third white
wife I think
um
all his kids are mixed
and then uh William Will Walker is one
of my best buddies in there he's a
black guy from the Army a little bit
older than me
he's 60 isn't he 60 you wouldn't know it
by looking at him no there's no way you
know that and um his wife I think he got
married right married to her yeah did
they get married are they still just
engage I think they got it married
she's a
um
Army Captain uh doctor
um she's medical I think she's a medical
doctor isn't she or she's just medical
staff he called her a doctor
she's white
um it's funny because all the black guys
with white women and all the black girls
are with white guys
but it's just by accident it's just
that's who they fill in with
in the scene yeah it doesn't really
you know
it's just kind of
if you're in that scene you're in that
scene you're you're judged by what your
cool factor is how you dress like who
your friends are the status that you
have
that's just really all it is yeah if
you're like a cool person yeah
yeah
granther said question if someone was
goth in high school but then became a
normie later in life do gods consider
them to be apostates
we did when I was in my 20s and 30s yeah
kind of when you get older you realize
that sometimes a girl's got bills to pay
I'm still always like really
disappointed you know like it like if I
meet somebody
um because this will happen sometimes
like I'll meet somebody like if I'm at
the store like they're you know working
there or something and they'll say like
oh you know I used to dress like that
like when I was you're in Florida
they'll be my age or something like that
and I'm always just kind of like I get
that sometimes you can't really dress
like that yeah but it does still kind of
like well grafters it does bum me out
Graham remember Gene petrowski
I was dating one of the little black
widow tattoo on her shoulder we went to
high school with her
she was got this [__] for most of her
life until she realized that she had
bills to pay and she's just a
soccer mom now you know what I mean
[__] married a dude that's into
football and just Michigan generic guy
you know at least on the surface he's
probably a nice guy
just just not in the scene you know
it just happens yeah like it takes over
yeah and I can see that happening you
know it's just that I mean oh God dudes
don't have any money there's no future
with a lot of them but the thing about
it is that I I can't really imagine
because it's just like such a big part
of my life and such a big part of my
personality that I think it would be
just really hard for me to like relate
to somebody that wasn't at least into
this some of the same [__] that I was
into like even somebody that wasn't into
goth music like they would at least have
to be into like horror movies or
something like that you know what I mean
yeah like similar
but because otherwise I'm like what the
[__] would I talk to them about it was
just kind of a frame of reference too
because if you look at me and Jan me and
Jen have been best friends and [__]
partners for [__] what almost 12 13
years
and if you were to talk to us outside
the show there's a lot of differences
between me and Jen a lot of differences
but we kind of have similar
back cultural backgrounds when it comes
to to the god scene so we kind of speak
the same language and
I think we're also kind of more
forgiving of each other
get it out yeah because there's kind of
a sense of camaraderie from the thing
you know so
it's so our differences the differences
that we do have are not quite as
important because you kind of have a
quantity we kind of have a shared kind
of cultural heritage I guess you could
say it'd be a good way to put it there's
no way I describe yeah I think that is a
good way it's like a cultural reference
yeah point to see what it is because I
know what she's thinking and how she
sees it that kind of [__] yeah I may not
agree with it but I know her Baseline
where she's her point of view I can I
can get it you know yeah
but still you know
we've been together probably 12 13 years
and we've really only fought a handful
of times yeah which that Mo that's and
we're together all the [__] time yeah
pretty much
I mean you know we do kind of Drive each
other crazy but
yeah it depends on what what's happened
it depends on yeah I mean and the thing
about it is that
it's it's different now because for a
while like when I was working at home
like you know from 2016 on like when I
got laid off then it just seemed like we
were together all the time because I was
always home working and you were always
here yeah and so like we
you know sometimes he'd be like okay I
gotta go out and do something like
something I hit the [__] away from me
first yeah for a little while but it
still didn't fight that much no not
really I think I think it counted less
than 10 times yeah when you say yeah
it's yeah and only maybe like five of
them that I would some of them were just
kind of like [__] [__] yeah I gotta go
it's not really a fight it's just
that will look sick of looking at your
face right
I mean everybody has that oh I think
most couples would not have survived the
[__] that we went through no way no I
don't think so no I don't think so
well I mean the thing about it like I
said even though we drive each other
crazy and we're very very different
people but I think that we always know
that we like have each other's backs you
know what I mean and I think that's kind
of like really important
yeah
yeah I'm not gonna [__] you over and you
know that right and you know that I
wouldn't [__] you over I just well I
don't do that I don't do that to people
I mean you would really
and not you specifically but a person
would really really have to [__] me over
really really hard before I would even
consider like retaliating like in the
same kind of way I can be like as
[__] evil as the next person but most
of the time I just feel like it's not
worth the effort well it's not necessary
and it's not really necessary so it's
just kind of like yeah if somebody did
something like really really [__]
horrible and unforgivable to me I might
retaliate in kind but I probably
wouldn't because I always just kind of
feel like well I'm just gonna be the
better [__] here yeah you know
that's just kind of the way I am it's
like why would I sync to that level
I don't [__] people over well you
getting back to work and then me doing
bike nights and [__] all that well did
the [__] come
okay did you [__] it up no no no
Tom broke it making sure a certain kind
of steroidal medicines are on the way
get messages from from my underground
crew of [__] Smugglers
yeah it's gonna be okay man don't worry
any day now
but yeah what um what was this what were
you saying oh it's just uh what was it
what was it [__] we were talking about
[__] people over
yeah I don't think oh what I was saying
is they're saying now you're going back
to work
and I'm doing bike nights and [__] we're
spending more time apart that's actually
pretty good because now we get out of
each other's hair for a while
you know and then because we were
together for [__] 24 7 for what
[__] six years yeah
like all the time we were always
together all the time all the [__]
time so
foreign
it's good to you know it's good to see
you come back home and like I've missed
you you know what I mean yeah like I
said before like you didn't even have a
chance like we didn't have a chance to
miss each other because we were always
like in each other's faces
like at all times but I mean it it was
better like when we moved in this house
because you know like I have my office
you have your man cave like I have my
own bathroom you have your own bathroom
so it's not we're not like constantly
piled on top of each other like I said I
went back to work which you know and I
think I might have to get a job too I
want to go work for Tom
well you should if you well I'm gonna
talk to him you know who told me to work
for Tom his mama she he needed to work
he has to work with my son he needs you
that's what he said he owes me some
money too yeah I'm gonna get him yo he
owes you money all right how much he owe
you 150. okay all right he he just loses
track I know I'll tell his secretary
yeah
um yeah Mr 88 said people grow some grow
into what others grow out of yeah and
then he said what's more sad is that
High School jock douche that's the exact
same 30 years later yeah I definitely
knew some people like that yeah that's
some like peaked in high school [__]
right yeah they're the same as they're
exactly the same as they were except
they're 40 pounds heavier and it ain't
good wait
yeah
I mean you could argue like yeah because
I was you know pretty gothy in high
school too yeah we didn't change but I
did but we didn't I mean yeah but we
changed in other ways too and the thing
about it is that
I I kind of see it as more
I I was pretty
um
aware of like the kind of person that I
was from like a very very young age like
as soon as I was old enough to like be
aware of it I was like I'm I want to be
I'm into creepy [__] yeah I didn't just
do just this though you know too you
know I was joining the military and
going overseas and getting involved in
[__] Contracting type work later on
and losing wives and [__] losing [__]
and gaining [__] and losing [__] and I
went through all that you know and so
I'd be away from the scene too I was
away from civilization for a while and
um
so
sometimes when I would talk this way you
know in front of the camera you know it
kind of leads people to believe that
[__] this is all we do now we did
other [__] too that was just kind of
like more like where we came from is
where we could go back to that's like
our social scene real similar
to where in other classes would be kind
of like the Outlaw motorcycle scene
it's like that it's just different
different kind of clientele
Jen is writing books horror books and
[__] true crime books so it's not
just scene stuff that's the launch pad
we launched things from that's home base
more than anything else
but that's not where
we our characters were really forged
parts of him were yeah but not all of it
I mean because like I said a lot of my
personality had to deal with just me
being really attracted to like spooky
[__] like from a very very young age
that was as soon as I was old enough to
know what I wanted to do she's making
products and selling them and you know
engineering stuff and making covers and
creating you know she's a Creator you
can't really Advance much as a person if
you're just [__] in a dance club all
the time
by the same token I mean it's good it's
good to blow off steam and it's good
like it's a good social outlet because
like you see the same people and you get
to hang out with people that are in the
same [__] as you and you know interact
face to face which is nice yeah but
that's not it right that's only that's
like I said that's your that's your
friends
and they're all checking back in with
each other by the same token
I think Bruce Dickinson from Iron Maiden
said that you never really mature as a
man if all you are is a rock star you
got to do all other [__] he became a
pilot
the airline pilot and did a bunch of
well we all bought businesses and ran
businesses you know just being on tour
all the time in a rock band you're going
to become Frozen at a certain age
because man that's just a lot of
traveling and doing shows same thing
over and over and over again
you can't really develop
I mean I've always been a big advocate
of whatever it is I always think it's
it's always good to like just keep
creating stuff or keep learning stuff or
just learn new [__] make [__] you know
what I mean whatever it is it doesn't
have to be anything complicated or
anything like that yeah and you know
this was this is this scene is was the
scene for us this is where we came from
but there's other scenes that you know
we're not involved in that [__]
might be for somebody else like they got
dudes like I said you talk about these
[__] Sports Jacks and [__]
they got their own scene man they those
dudes probably do well in that they've
got their own groupies they uh [__]
got their own businesses they make money
you know there's a lot of money in the
[__] Sports the sports industry
and uh I respect physicality and guys
that [__] are athletes that that you
know I like that [__] too I'm just not
really into those games that much I
really don't care about football or
basketball or anything but you know the
guys that are doing it now I got my
hat's off to them you know that's that's
hard work it takes a lot of talent a lot
of traded
which is not my thing
um
but I understand it
you know and you could have greatness
there you know yeah I'm sure there are
people in those sports bars cutting all
kinds of deals and [__] uh you know
making something out of themselves it's
just not what I want to do yeah you know
well yeah I'm not sitting on it yeah I'm
not gonna [__] on other people's it's
just not you know it doesn't interest me
at all and it's like but I understand
other people yeah and I don't want them
hoarding it on my [__] either yeah you
know what I mean stay with you all at
yeah
that's what I mean by the same token I
wouldn't go wandering into like some
[__] Country Western Bar because it's
not my deal you know what I mean I don't
like it I don't want any part of it yeah
so I don't want those [__] in
my [__] either like pointing and
laughing at me granther said I think I'm
a latent goth appreciate the aesthetic
in music but wouldn't fit in with the
committed well you didn't you didn't
start at the right time
teeds at least
at least that's where you make your name
and uh that's where you meet your first
goth girlfriends and that's where you
kind of you can't you can just hang out
in those scenes as an older guy just
watch but your time has kind of passed
and where you can make a name for
yourself you should have been in there
in your 20s and your 30s putting time in
meeting people and screwing the right
girls but here's the thing man there are
guys that can come in that just have a
certain way about them that can do well
um we had a guy named Bill
what was his last name remember his bill
he was uh biggest static guy yeah yeah
yeah um he's a big Cuban big Cuban uh
Floridian Cuban guy what the [__] was
his uh it's right on the top of my
tongue I can't remember
I'll think of it wasn't Santos was it
Bill no Rivera Bill Rivera Bill Rivera
was his name
Bill Rivera worked for the uh
drug industry okay and his he would go
from hospital to hospital selling
packages to drugs to these doctors
he was a six-figure plus [__]
salesman all right
and he was probably about six four
big Cuban good dude good looking just
meaty you know he looked like a he
looked like he could have been a
football player
and he came into the goth scene nothing
goth about this guy at all the way he
looked but he was a hit he was a hit he
was screwing our friend
um uh Sonia yeah you know and she was
the gothiest of the goth she's [__]
around Bill Rivera and it [__]
so he's a good dude though he's a good
dude yeah he was a good dude
I haven't seen him in a long time he
doesn't come around last time my son was
probably about a year ago at mannequins
yeah that's right we did see him at
mannequins like a while back and um
I would probably say that his background
was more kind of like high school jock
he was kind of had that background I
think but he very charismatic he had the
right look he had to treat people yeah
he wasn't like obnoxious or arrogant or
yeah an understanding of different
cultures so he could come right into the
goth scene and just treat people as
people and talk and understand and look
at things in a different way and go yeah
yeah okay yeah I see what you're talking
about you know so you could understand
yeah he did it because sometimes you get
like people that don't really and they
come in and like start like asking you
stupid questions or making assumptions
about you based on certain things and
yeah like you know he brought a buddy
with him the first thing to do the buddy
did is [__] say hey man do you know
anybody that has any Coke
so he assumed that [__] weird dream
of dealing drugs you know what I mean
another thing bill just grabs him
because get it get out of it yeah he
immediately knew it's like he
immediately knew like he was thinking
yeah yeah yeah
well it's just kind of like you know how
there's like the certain type of dude
that always think like oh goth chicks
are all yeah we're gonna [__] all these
guys or like yeah that's the hardest
thing not hookers but like they think
they're all into freaky [__] yeah they
they think they can get it and I'm just
like yeah that's not that's gonna go
yeah they jump into a golf club thinking
that it's [__] a meat market and
Gotham are the hardest women to [__]
get they're the hardest ones they're all
set on Expert
and they all have [__] these little
issues and all this different cultural
things and yeah
talking to not really talking to a goth
girl that you don't know if you're not a
goth is be the equivalent of trying to
run through a Minefield you're gonna
step on a [__] mind
you know you don't know what you're
dealing with
we're the worst seriously if you're in
that culture you you you kind of you
have a better chance but even another
goth who has has
they're difficult
difficult to ask [__]
well it's just because and this is
unless you're Peter Murphy
which is a cute ass [__] skinny ass
[__] goth dude then yeah you know if
you're wearing the right [__] clothes
and everything that they're looking at
yeah you're acting like an ass on her
and [__] ignoring her then yeah
you'll probably get that but you know no
you come up with some thirsty [__]
moves on some guy check she's gonna go
get the [__] out of here well and the
thing about it too is that and I'm sure
this is the case with anybody that looks
different from the norm or anything uh
and has for a long time no matter what
it is but you get stupid comments and
stupid questions and [__] like that all
the time yeah so you know you just kind
of get sick of it yeah and you've heard
it all you know what I mean we've heard
I've heard like every stupid pickup line
every stupid movie reference every
stupid dude trying to be cool by making
this remark and really he sounds like an
idiot you know I've heard all of it yeah
and every other chick has to yeah so the
second you come up and like open your
mouth I'm just like I'm Gonna Give You
All dudes some advice
give you all dudes some Club advice this
is this this advice would probably work
in any scene
but it would very much work in the goth
scene or would help you in the god scene
but it'd probably work in any scene if
you start going into another into a club
assume that everybody knows each other
because they probably do
assume that everybody's dated each other
because they probably have
don't get in with it for sure around
here yeah don't get in don't go in there
and start
scooping in on the women all right on
your first night there you're gonna It's
Gonna Take You months to know that
[__] that scene
and you want to make friends with the
dudes first
that way you can get information in the
background of Who's Who
who's been you know you must know the
battlefield
you have to know the code oh your enemy
right
that's before you do anything and then
you have to figure out what it is these
women are looking for all right and
[__] the Golf Scene is superficial
just this
if you're dressed [__] up and they're
you're not gonna get anything okay
now now going back to Bill Bill wasn't
dressed [__] up he was he was dressed
good for
what he was which is a professional guy
all right but he was real
um charismatic and he got to know
everybody first yeah well you can tell
yeah he wasn't thirsty like he wasn't
right yeah he was just hanging out right
and have fun buying other people's
drinks and playing politics he was a
Salesman and I was actually talking to
the dudes right yeah you know making
friends making friends with old dudes
and [__] so because he was willing to
put in the time to get to know everybody
yeah right and in in general
when you go to these clubs
if the women are ignoring you they're
they're not playing hard to get they're
ignoring you because they're not
interested in you
now they might get interested in you
over time
if they keep seeing you and you keep
impressing them over time
but
don't [__] just run up on some chick
and try to drop your nuts on some groups
I mean that's true in anything you don't
know really that's always like the
[__] rookie mistake yeah
I always feel like the more if you just
kind of hang out you don't have to do
anything you don't I mean you could just
hang out just because as long as you're
not obnoxious douche you know you could
just come in have a drink maybe you like
some of the music maybe you dance or
something like that don't go like you
know
don't go scoping on people don't just
like hang out and like the more you do
that the more you get like recognized
and then then you can kind of start
talking to people and then yeah I mean
don't just run up some up on some ground
go I think you are beautiful you might
as just go look I want to suck your
[__]
no
you talk I'd rather you did not you talk
to a woman unprompted it's going to be
something like those are some [__]
great shoes
or I love your outfit you look great
and then just leave it at that walk away
you'll actually get some [__] points
if you walk the [__] away after that
because I mean a surprising amount of
dudes won't do it won't do it they'll
just stay there next time you see her
next week you might actually be okay and
then you know you you've already or you
know just don't talk about her
it's got to be about something else
because they get dudes [__]
bombarding them all the time
thirsty [__] online tell them
how beautiful they are that as soon as
soon as you simp you become you join the
army of simps she's not interested in
The Sims okay well see I always thought
it was better to if you must compliment
I mean I really wish you would but if
you have to it's always better to
compliment like a choice that she made
like an outfit that she put on or
something like that like not in a sexual
way but that's why shoes are good like
oh I really like this boots or whatever
or jewelry or something like that like
um doesn't apply to women if a woman
says she likes your boots or shoes is
she is she subtly saying you're hot
um I don't know maybe but then maybe she
might just be like I like your boots
because I've told chicks I like their
boots before and I didn't like you know
I didn't want to have sex with them I
was just like I just really like this
boot you know what I mean sometimes
that's all it is okay you know sometimes
there's no underlying I get that there's
no underlying I get that one with these
boots
oh let's see if a woman does it to a man
yeah oh okay
um with these boots get a lot when I'm
riding maybe maybe okay I kind of feel
in that situation it's 50 50. yeah it's
probably like 50 50. like sometimes
chicks might just like your boots yeah
um but yeah so probably like half of
them are probably flirting yeah right
that's what I figured and I bet you it's
the older half
probably yes because now they've gotten
old and they're like they don't give a
[__] you're right they're just gonna
like yeah above 40 they're flirting with
you right probably I figured yeah
granther said many dudes don't realize
that when girls get dolled up they
aren't trying to impress dudes they're
trying to impress other girls yeah yeah
it's competitive Behavior with other
women and honestly when usually if I get
like a lot of effusive comments it's
usually like from other girls yeah like
in the ladies where you go in the ladies
room it's like yeah oh my God your hair
yeah or your boobs yeah or something
yeah when she's wearing Rollo cut stuff
the ones that molester are girls
taking the 99. well because dudes know a
lot of dudes know better they know
better right yeah because I because I
have resting [__] face and I was like I
will absolutely punch you yeah but um
you know guess what what it's 8 30. oh
[__] yeah yeah we we better go running
in my mouth yeah we gotta we gotta get
ready to go yeah I gotta like I said my
makeup's ready I just gotta like throw
some clothes on and all right I gotta
sponge off and all right maybe they're
noticing Tom's boobs not boots yeah they
did I told you before when I was dressed
up as Bane and [__] for Halloween she
standing right behind me and I'm walking
to walking past the bar of mannequins
and I had that mask on they really
couldn't see my face so I was kind of
depersoned and I was regularly getting
grabbed by girls in their [__] 20s
yeah and one of them reached out and
just grabbed my [__] titty and just
squeezed it like that right in front of
Jenny yeah and I was like what the [__]
she dug she dug it back in but I had him
grab my arm you know I walked by and
grabbed my [__] bicep and don't want
me to leave when she's right with me
yeah yeah
they didn't know probably didn't know
how old I was
but they usually don't know how old I am
in a club
I don't think that I'm in early 40s late
30s and like I said you had that mask on
so they couldn't really see your face
either which makes you not a person
which makes you like yeah like Anonymous
yeah so and they were probably real
[__] up yeah they're [__] up because
it was Halloween and the place was
[__] jam-packed and everybody was
really inebriated yeah
but yeah so uh yeah we better um well
you think about it man of course they
could grab a man's titty what am I gonna
do call the cops I'm gonna [__]
slapper so I guess it is I guess it'd be
funny if he did slap right
okay
you touch me
like Christopher Walken yeah yeah yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
that makes me laugh every single time I
think about it all right this ain't
coming out of the wall all right all
right I'm gonna go get dressed and we're
gonna go out so you guys have a
wonderful evening thank you all for
stopping by and hanging out with us uh
and have a good day tomorrow we'll be
back on Sunday probably gonna be talking
about Training Day
because Louie sent us that and we're
going to be watching that probably
tomorrow night uh so yeah so hopefully
you can join us on Sunday for that and
we will see you guys uh then good